I'm gonna go back for it
today I would like to uh
shift the uh gears a little bit then
talk more specifically about computer
science than about mathematics
um but first are there questions on the
homework assignment that I should get
out of the way
first everybody understands it fully
well enough to come to the TA office
hours this afternoon if you don't right
okay good
uh
so computer science uh
is is the you know the name of the
department that's teaching this course
is cs209 and uh it's called mathematical
writing just because we don't we didn't
really have a an adjective in English
saying computer scientifical writing uh
or whatever the right word should be
um
maybe there never will be aware for it
but uh you know computer science is a
big mouthful but we haven't but
informatic writing informatical writing
would that be the proper the proper
European term I don't know
um
uh well it's
uh in in in other fields that use
mathematics that aren't specifically uh
doing doing central mathematics uh you
still have all of the all of the
problems that arise in mathematical
Exposition but you also have have other
ones and uh and it turns out that for
example a a typist the technical typist
who has to work for the computer science
department
has to know everything that a typist in
the mass department has to know but a
lot more about because there's
algorithms that involve I mean I this
sounds chauvinistic to say this but I
but uh
I I'm involved in hiring typists since I
mean you know it's just it and and so I
want to try to explain some of the uh
some of the things that that make
computer science uh an extra add-on
complexity
um to the problem and then see how
discuss some of the answers that that
are
um that are showing up and so on uh so I
brought a bunch of stuff with me and I'm
not sure I can find all the right all
the right materials in time
unfortunately I didn't give myself
enough kind of
to locate everything that my first
example was going to be based on on
polish mathematic mathematics uh
um and uh this and and I had remembered
something incorrectly see your homework
problem is is uh is based on a you know
a paper and unpolished Mathematics I
thought this would be a nice continuity
because I published also in a Polish
mathematics journal and I and I included
algorithms in my paper and so I was
going to show you the the way they
screwed up when they tried to typeset my
paper and the algorithms came out
looking terrible well I found out as I
was looking through the files just
before class that uh they didn't do such
a bad job after all and so I had to had
to go to some more files to get to get
the proper examples
turnout
that when I wrote when I wrote a letter
to this is a journal called
actaarithmetica and it's and this letter
was stated 77 and and I I did write a a
letter to them saying uh just describing
the fact that I'm using floor and
ceiling functions
that um uh that they didn't have in
their journal and so I was making an
argument for them to do that but the but
the uh so that so in the paper in the
proofs that I got I had to uh
I had to tell them where to uh where to
Lop off the corners of these of these
symbols and this is all hand set and
metal type and so on this is how you can
see it's polish
um and uh
but then when I got to the algorithms
where I thought I was where I thought I
was going to find that they had they had
great problems that eternal hell I had
anticipated the whoops I had anticipated
the problems earlier when I sent it in
and so I marked the marked my manuscript
up very carefully so that they wouldn't
get that that you know they would they
would have that working out pretty well
although there is some indentation in
the number six was missing here and so
on these are the galley proofs but uh
but they didn't but this uh came out
reasonably
um reasonably the way I wanted
um and and uh the mod operator here
um which should be in Roman type they
didn't you know they just made it as one
long identifier K mod H but other you
know and um but otherwise it
the most common mistake out of prenary
typically makes when you send them
something and don't knock it up
carefully is this colon equal sign now
uh they'll love to put the colon
far to the left and then a space and
then an equal sign
but so this wasn't the example that I
wanted that that I was expecting it to
be
um now these conventions for type
setting algo-like languages were
developed by the ACM
Myrtle Kellington was the executive
editor of ACM Publications through the
60s and and spent a lot of time
developing standards as to for
indentation and bold face italic when
you go into Roman like a comments will
be in Roman that identifiers will be in
italic except the
the uh you know numeral will still be
Roman Sigma 2 and and she worked out
putting the colon and equal sign
together and so on when algo was defined
there was no thought given to these
questions of how it actually typeset it
um and uh but Myrtle was in on it from
the very beginning of publishing the
report and worked on it together with
Peter nauer in order to get something
that that looked that looked well so
when algo 60 was published in 1960 it
had a nice looking report and it was due
to this uh this special work uh and it
can only be appreciated by
by knowing how many things that was
different from what the typesetters were
doing on
otherwise now I think I do have an
example in the other in the other folder
here yes are you going to discuss like
could you get a reference for that or to
which now for the uh
business about why it's bold face why
the uh oh yeah now I don't believe she's
ever published her her uh uh you know
her pale her pages of style rules for
for setting out golf type she just you
know they she uh gave it to the people
at Waverly press and and other other
journals that want to publish
alcohol-like languages have written to
ACM and gotten it from their
headquarters but I don't think it's ever
appeared in print these these style
rules maybe that's not the question
you're asking though I'm wondering yeah
um
okay well
um it's something that uh uh that
yeah
Reeds seems to read better if they if
there's a way to distinct if there's a
way for them to be uh to be
typographically different now I haven't
seen all the different possible
experiments that went into it but
but the uh
um
the having the uh uh okay let me I guess
I should say something about the their
if you look at the old Publications uh
before alcohol what the what what
algorithms look like I think that would
probably be the best the best uh answer
but the hardest thing the the the
um uh let me see
uh Fortran was all caps and and uh they
would types at all caps
um and the and caps on the typefaces
were not made to look good when they
were used in such and mixed with uh with
numbers and and uh parenthesis and
things like this and and have a long
pieces of text in all caps and they and
uh not not having a fixed width font was
was uh
because in Fortran you needed to know
what was in column five and of a card
and for a comment uh and and uh or was
it column six or four I forget and when
you punch the cards anyway people would
there were a lot of Pub of papers
published that used um uh that that that
needed a fixed width font in order to
make it make sense and and the
programming the programs always look
look looked pretty awful if you just had
them all caps and things like that now
that that was the environment before
alcohol and um
now with El gold they decided that this
there were the concept of reserved words
and so these words begin procedure so on
we're we're to be different from the
identifier begin in procedure which were
which were legal identifiers if you look
at the original definition of algo
um
and therefore the original
implementations of algol required a
you wouldn't just say b-e-g-i-n in your
program but you would say uh I think it
was like at sign b-e-g-i-n in order to
mean this is the reserved word
b-e-g-i-n as opposed to the identifier b
e g i n which you're also allowed to use
so you were supposed to have some some
way of and and the compiler was supposed
to treat this as if it was a single a
single letter
issue reserved word was in the
definition of alcohol strictly speaking
a a equivalent to the letter A or B or
something like that it was a uh it was a
a letter of the uh of the terminal
alphabet terminal symbol alphabet for
the language
um and uh it wasn't until uh until a
couple you know some years went by
before people realized that they would
be much better to reserve the reserved
words and not allow them as identifiers
but that but in Fortran uh there's no
such thing as a reserved word I mean you
can have a variable called do 5i
and do 5i equals three it's different
from do five I equals three comma n
because uh the latter is a do statement
the first one is an assignment to the
variable do five on
and um so so uh these these conventions
for for actually delimiting uh uh or and
separating out the functions of things
uh developed about about then and I
think it it's turned out to be a uh uh a
useful key a useful way that even though
you're using three different you're
using bold Roman and italic uh they seem
to mix in a in a way that that
psychologically uh blends with with our
understanding of the reading so so I
don't know
uh now let me see if I can find the one
in the the example of a of a of a
typesetter who hadn't
gotten the
hadn't done computer science before
um
look like I'm not sure this is the right
yeah yeah this one oh my man this one's
really awful okay good
okay and this turned out this is in fact
it was American mathematical monthly uh
the uh and and so surprisingly this
these are Galley cruise from the math
monthly in uh
1984. so so uh
actually fairly fairly recent here I'm
I'm describing a a using an algo-like
language where I'm describing some of
Eric Bishop's constructive mathematics
uh which is a
um
a book that he that that writes where he
where every um every proof in it is
really an algorithm and uh but his
algorithms go Way Beyond the normal data
structures of computer science and I
tried to put it into a computer science
I tried to put his his mathematical
language into computer science notation
from one of the one of the pages
um I guess I tell you what this this
article is it's called um
algorithmic syncing and mathematical
thinking and it's trying to uh to
analyze what what it is that that
mathematicians do and is it different
from what computer scientists do and I
and I took a sample of books and I
looked at page 100 on each book and I
and then I tried to boil down what what
would what
um what things would an AI program to do
mathematical reasoning have to have to
learn in order to be able to handle page
100 on these various books and uh and uh
and one of the books I chose was uh was
a constructive or the book of
constructive mathematics is assuming
that maybe there would be some
difference between that and and the
other and the mathematics written by
um
other people well now so I try to do
this in a computer language so here you
see one you know one of the first things
that types there doesn't know to put up
to put the colons next to the equal sign
here they use the very funny symbol I
had never seen before with Saturday uh
um a little
tiny little dots after the equal sign uh
completely wrong
but they they uh maybe we're trying to
it's something on this and then uh
um Lemma 5 here you see is in Roman here
it's in italic it's got to be consistent
between the two
and uh when I got to um
um and then and then when I got well
yeah when I got to this one I they it
really started to break their system I
mean look at these lines all smashed
into each other
uh this is a
is that an upside down question mark I
don't know if everything is all screwed
up so but now when you finally see the
article in print
um it might look look like it was simple
but the actual formatting of this uh was
was sufficiently different from what
these people who do mathematics every
day uh normally do that they that they
uh they just uh it was sort of terrified
by this but I was talking about the
different data structures now you see
here's a data structure where the
variable is a
is a function that takes uh that takes
one parameter times itself into the
positive reels and uh so that's a data
type where
or for a local variable of this
procedure and uh
uh people who are in my
304 class last year where we talked
about the
uh where we talked about complicated
data types we will recognize some of
this as
uh I mean this type Lambda calculus
that's now becoming an important
research topic but anyway the I'm
talking here about the the method of
presentation just just to illustrate
that um that there's some there's a
style rules things that go into these
that are that are fairly extensive and
not
not the same as ordinary mathematics so
this is this is one add-on to to
mathematics
now another
another thing I alluded to that that
computer science seem to need that
mathematics didn't have was the idea of
a style of type with fixed widths we we
refer to strings of characters and we
refer to things in that that person
types in a on a on a terminal and these
appear on a on a screen uh usually you
know in a font that has fixed pitch so
that you so that things will line up
below each other on on
on adjacent lines now
um so when I when I came to publish the
volume one of the art of computer
programming the
the
Publishers said it was going to be
impossible to have
to have uh a fixed a fixed width type
um I should I would have to use variable
with because they're they they were
doing it with monotype and monotype had
room for 256 characters and they had to
be a certain thing and they they already
had bold metallic and Roman how are they
going to get another style in there too
um but I was very uh uh insistent that
was going to be important to have
something like this and and so uh the
people at s and Wesley went down to the
shop and and finally they worked out a
system where the guy said yes we can
figure out how we can throw out some of
these Greek letters you aren't using
very much as often and we'll put those
in by hand and and we'll put in that
we'll put in a fixed type and they found
a nice
style of type that would that would
blend with the um
with the other
um with the other uh with the other
things well I think this was the this is
the original monotype thing that they
where they mix this typewriter Style
with
um with italic here and with um with
Roman and and uh and then there's bold
also
here uh and the one change I had to make
was that we had to have a we had to be
on television between o and zero
and that was and so though this o here
was specially designed for my book uh to
be to be very Square uh to distinguish
it from the zero which uh must appear
somewhere nearby here here's a zero down
the bottom here
so the O was made was made specially for
the for this book in the 60s and then
they figured out a way to actually put
the uh to put these
these things I was using words like
contents and so on um in a technical
sense where I wanted it where I wanted
something to be typographically
different most important thing was I was
I was defining an assembler assembler
language where the where the uh the
fields were important as to where things
appeared in the in columns and so on so
fixed width was important at that time
um that still seems to be uh true today
that is
when you write a a manual about computer
programs
um it's quite often the case that you'll
want to have the examples that reflect
something that the computer that you
type into the computer or that the
computer shows on the screen or
something like that you'll want that in
a specific type that will that will be a
fixed pitch
and we'll we'll be specific so so uh
this was now now we we intentionally in
the 60s we were we we confronted this
and said uh does you know computer
science is a is a you know the first
computer science programs have just been
established is there any are there any
uh
um
things that make it different from what
uh what what other journals are doing
computer science journals that ought to
be uh that ought to be thought out and
experimented with and we we face this uh
consciously in those times and and uh
and the typographers that came up with
these Solutions and and uh they there's
now still with us I guess
um
okay let's see uh I I had several things
I wanted to bring up today and I'll
probably come out and kill your order
but the presentation of algorithms is
one of the main is one of the main
things of course that distinguishes
computer science from other things we
have to describe how we present a method
and uh so
um I um
was writing this series of books that I
knew was going to take me many years to
finish and the question was how was I
going to present the algorithms in this
book in these books
and
um I knew I wanted to have one level
that was that was very low level so that
the uh so that the the ideas about going
from a low-level Machine level up to the
up to higher level would be clear but
what should I use for the high level
language
um
uh programming languages in the 60s were
in a terrible state of flux and still
they are I mean we still don't have the
everybody's favorite programming
language uh hasn't hasn't hasn't come
along and so I knew that whatever if I
took a particular programming language
it would it would soon
I would alienate uh 70 of the people who
are going to read the book
um and the and uh and even in the others
they would probably not have that
language implemented on their machine
and so they would think uh they
shouldn't buy the book so I wanted them
to buy the book I wanted every way to
buy the book so
um
so I decided not to use a programming
language but to use English instead
and uh
I'm going to discuss the pros and cons
of this but later on then Jeff Allman
and Alejo hopcraft this came up with
their their book which which covered
many of the similar topics and they
decided to use pigeon alcohol in their
in their book which which worked
successfully it was it was not it was it
was sufficiently different from alcohol
nobody would ever try to actually type
these programs in and run them but it
was still exposed to it by that time
people were used enough to that to that
kind of language that they could that
they they felt it was reasonably
readable
um still
um I've gotten many letters from people
saying that they appreciate the way that
I give algorithms in English because
then they actually read them they it
looks like they're that it's something
to read and so they read them they get
caught you know they don't realize it's
going to be but they but they actually
do read them and so they said that was a
good idea so so I get that uh so the the
style I decided to use in this books was
based on something that I had actually
seen in the Russian literature uh in the
50s the uh where they
uh an algorithm was was given
schematically with a very with a with a
flowchart that had very very little
detail in in um in the steps but it gave
a picture of what was going on with the
idea was that you had one or two
keywords in a uh maybe three in this
case here's one three uh which would
describe
uh the purpose of that step and um and
if you understood the algorithm this
would be a helpful flowchart it wouldn't
be good enough by itself but then so I
so I kept these keywords in this at the
beginning of the step and I and the
keywords end with appear with a question
mark if it's a if there's a sort of a
test going on in a period otherwise and
I tried to find these two words that
would boil down the whole idea of the
step and then um uh later on I uh this
would also make a reasonable comment to
put in an assembly language program E1
fine remainder
um
and so then so I decided for present
presenting an algorithm I would use
something like presenting a theorem it
ended with this with this black symbol
that I also use at the end of ethereum
um and I give a title to it like I give
theorem a I would have algorithm e and
uh I would give a description at the
beginning the way a theorem has a
description of what's going on
um
in in the
in the algorithm I'm I'm just talking
English here so I'm not I'm not making
assignment statements or anything
although I well it's time to save my I
guess so I have this left Arrow
operation which which I which isn't
exactly English but
um needed that that's something that
computer science has that mathematics
doesn't have
um and then there's parenthetical
remarks that that state state things
about the algorithm that turn out to be
useful uh but not I mean useful to
understand it and and as I learned more
in the Years went by I learned more
about the
invariant the idea of invariance and so
the con the comments on my on the
algorithms I wrote after 1968 or
something like that would would be
consciously done with the idea that this
was that the things I'm putting in
parenthesis are often the invariants
that a person would would use in a
formal proof of the correctness of the
algorithm
oh anyway now this this was the style of
present of presenting algorithms that I
use in the book and I'm going to
continue to use it on the other hand I
can't consider it to be a success
because
um of the following thing people have
tried to copy it
and you might say that's a mark of
success but the fact is that none of the
copies that I've seen do it do it
well at least I I don't like the way
they've done they they copied this style
and they said and and unfortunately they
say now I'm going to present an
algorithm in canoe's style and then they
proceed to botch my style completely I
mean they all of the all of the things
of it that I consider important they
they uh change and so the fact is then
it must be a personal style that only
works for me
uh so so you should find one that works
for you but but don't say that it's mine
then that's all
um
okay but but uh in more recent papers I
have been when I you know in my books
I've adopted this style the book of art
of computer programming this is a
project I started in 1962 and uh
you know maybe 20 years from now I'll
I'll finish it so it's a long ongoing
thing I can't just up and change the
style every every so often
um
but the uh
uh the but one of the most more recent
papers that I'm writing
um I'll be using a style that's much
better as I showed you I had algo like
you know alcohol-like languages here in
my in the paper and uh and I'm
in fact this is
this is very close to alcohol accepted
once in a while it uses uh
well I'm not sure this divide operation
everyone every once in a while if I you
know mod maybe wasn't in alcohol
specifically but for but um but Pascal
has it but Pascal's mod is is flaky uh
so anyway I'm still using an algo like
style in this in this in this article
and intended to do that as depending on
the the class of readers that I
that I assume
now
um
I've got a handout which for what I
would like to talk about on Wednesday at
some length possibly also it'll carry
over to Friday
pass these out to Tracy
actually we got a whole bunch here why
not overdo it
and the handout is based on
um
is based on an idea that I that I've
been trying to push called literate
programming
and and this uh this was an article then
that uh that John Bentley wrote in the
communications of the ACM this was May
686.
um where he uh did me the great favor of
popularizing my ideas in in one of the
best American journals of I mean for for
having a lot of readers uh and uh this
is called programming yes yes yes guest
oyster this is called programming pearls
and he called and he caught he said it
was a special guest oyster
um John is a is a uh a good writer
now
I'll tell you now now I hope you read
this in between today's class and
Wednesday I'm not going to read it to
you now but the but I I did write this
article before in the computer Journal
and uh and I got a a note from John
Bentley's saying why did I publish this
in the computer Journal because
Americans ought to read this and they
never read the computer Journal there's
a British the British computer Journal
British computer Society Channel and I
said John I I wrote it in the British
computer Journal because I thought
Americans were illiterate and they would
never care about this sort of thing
um uh it was only people in Britain that
know anything about writing and uh in
fact I waited until until I uh
um until I had a trip to England until I
was going to England for I guess I had
some trip to Wales that I mentioned uh
last week
when I was going to the British Isles
the
um
I saved up that was the time when I when
I when I gave the talk launching this
this idea and so in London I gave the I
gave a talk into the British computer
society called literate programming and
I I think that this is one of the
biggest ideas to come out of my work on
Tech actually uh so so I'm rather proud
of this if you don't like it uh try to
conceal that fact from me uh because I'm
you know you see I'm tickled pink with
the idea but but uh the the uh I found
that uh that uh as I was as I was facing
the problem of how to explain the tech
program to a wider audience that that
this this forced me to think about
presenting a program in different ways
I've ever done before and the way that
they finally started writing it when I
did the second draft of tech was was for
me a a radical change in the way I write
programs and it I don't and uh for me
it's if I had finally discovered the
right way to write programs after after
25 years and and uh I wanted to go back
and rewrite every program I'd ever done
in this new style and I was really um I
was really into uh you know uh thrilled
with the way things were working
something something clicked it was it
was a bunch of old ideas that when you
put together in this package all of a
sudden they all worked very well for me
and so I got
excited about it and I and I decided to
have a nice buzzword to go with it
called literate programming which would
then be my way of having revenge on the
people who had been talking about
structured programming for many years
and and thereby making me feel guilty by
whenever I wrote an unstructured program
now I could make them feel even guiltier
if they wrote an illiterate program and
then so I so I was I had this all
figured out and I decided to launch it
in England because there I thought that
I was getting people who really who
really could write better now I'm I'm
um of course I was joking when I said
that but there's a little grain of Truth
in this and namely as a as the editor of
of computer journals I've found that if
I take a a random Journal written by a
random Journal article written by uh um
someone in Britain that has now been
submitted for publication uh chances are
very good that it's well written and if
I take a random
Journal article I've submitted for
publication from America chances are
very poor that it's well written and I I
don't think it's only the genes that
control this there's something about
there's something else and there's some
it must be something in the educational
system or whatever and that's why I did
decide really to to talk about literate
programming first in the British
computer journal and then and to the
British computer Society
um
on the other hand I was glad to see that
John Bentley liked it and he said he
would like to popularize the idea and
let Americans know about it and so he
wrote this this column which I'm handing
out now because I want to talk about
literate programming more on Wednesday
and Friday please read it between now
and then it's uh so he first just
introduces it then then at the end
um he has the last piece is the program
itself the last page is the program is
is a short example of of what I hope is
a literate Pro program I wrote it in in
two or three hours but it's still um
uh an example
that uh that he liked will have to print
so
um that's
that's the the intro on on it now what
is the ID what is the basic idea though
besides this buzzword literature
programming and the main the main idea
is that
um
that combining that okay the main idea
is to is to treat a computer program as
a piece of literature
to to imagine the day when there will be
a Pulitzer Prize given for the best
computer program of the year that uh
that uh when you're when you and and
when you when you write a program you
should think of it of yourself as an
Expositor for human readers not as an
instructor of this of a of an inanimate
computer
uh this this helps greatly in fact in in
making the program better uh even for
the computer's sake
um because you get it right
uh much faster uh every teacher knows
that they when when presenting an
algorithm to a class and trying to think
of how you how you uh what the steps are
as you write the Blackboard or something
talking to students
um you get much more clarity than if
you're sitting there and hacking away
and just and just tossing together some
statements and then you let the computer
play around with them for a while and
you're doing a one-off program you you
usually go through many drafts of it uh
if you do the second way but if you if
but the ones that present to somebody
else when you're explaining this like
actually thinking of explaining it to
another human being as you're writing it
you tend to get it right the first time
um and uh now if you think of so you so
I think of uh of uh of myself instead as
a programmer essayist at the same at
this at the same time I'm trying to uh
trying to explain what it does and this
makes my program better and I tried to
explain in this paper some of the ways
in which that that happens and then but
then there's a method of uh of uh of
actually of actually doing it and that
is to organize a large program as um in
in modules and everyone knows that uh
the best way to uh to to understand
complexity is to understand the simple
parts of it and to understand the simple
ways in which the parts go together and
then you can understand the complex
whole and so you break down a complex
program into parts and then you the idea
is to explain each part by itself and to
explain how how the parts relate to each
other and then you've got your program
um and uh for this uh I I remembered the
trick about technical writing that I
told you about earlier that is that I
try to explain things twice once
formally and once informally uh and so
that's the style that I decided to
freeze into this uh to this method of
programming where I would start with an
informal description so every every
module begins with with text
um
and ends with Pascal it ends with with
formal computer program but begins with
informal text and these are
complementary to each other just in the
way that uh that when you're writing a
paper mathematics that I said earlier
you you give a formula and you say the
non-increasing vectors and then you say
that these are vectors then you give the
formal definition of what those vectors
are
um
so I froze that into the into a style of
writing computer programs where where a
person uh sits at a term and what well
actually you compose this thing I show
you the way it looks on your terminal
uh it looks like this and so I have a
special control symbol that says I'm
beginning a new section and I start
typing away here giving like the
informal comments and then I get to
another this special symbol again coming
in here followed by our less than sign
which is going to be here's going to be
the name of the name of that module
the name of the module is called program
to print
um okay take a look at it here now it's
called program to print the first
thousand prime numbers two this two
means it's module number two and um in
module number one uh the the code was
the program to print the first thousand
prime numbers too the the this number at
the end of the module name always tells
where you'd look for the module like
racial program for is module number four
Etc
other constants of the program five so
the now inside module two I have a
program here
program to print the first thousand
prime numbers and it's given here
completely but this this also involves
other references to to a code that goes
somewhere else that I haven't written
yet haven't explained yet this is 543
I'm going to get to them when I when
it's time for in the X position and when
when a person reading the program I
would be interested in knowing about the
details but I don't declare everything
first the way a compiler needs to know
when it reads it I'm declaring things in
the order in which a human being wants
to read it
and so this is uh
the idea of the of the programming
system which is which is uh
called Web I guess I told you that we
chose web after
a bunch of other names were considered
but based on Roger's thesaurus
uh trying to think and and and was one
of the few
three letter words that hadn't been used
yet before a computer system name
fine
and uh web sounds a little spidery and
and so on at first but it also
uh has some nice aspects and we got to
like the name the name Webb in fact I
went to Germany uh shortly after this
trip to England and
and I found out that
Vape was the word for for weaving
and uh the Latin word for weaving is
Texas and so everything was coming
together
now so now at the computer terminal I
sit and type something that looks like
this and uh once I and and the name of a
section tends to be rather long and so I
allow in I allow it to abbreviate it in
the file and uh and uh the uh the
computer figures out that that this was
actually programmed to print the first
thousand prime numbers because that that
longer identifier had already appeared
earlier appearancy
um so so these three dots are actually
there I've actually typed those three
dots these three dots I didn't these
three dots are on our Ellipsis that that
indicate uh what it would look like so
then then I have this uh I have this
computer file written in written in this
style where I alternate between x uh
informal and formal and then I have so
that's called the web file I have two
programs that read web files one of them
is called weave which uh which converts
the web file to a tech file and Tech
will print will will print the output
and this actually was printed by Tech
this this uh is the output of of weave
you know so so you take the web file you
weave it and you and then you take it
and that that and you get and this is
what what you get an output
um the other but there's another branch
and that is you run the Tango program on
the web file and that produces a pascal
program the Pascal compiler can compile
that and run it
and uh now that's another uh another
important issue I think about computer
programs if you're ever going to publish
computer programs that are supposedly
running computer programs this has to be
the computer has to be in charge of the
type setting there's just too many
things that can go wrong between
um uh between trying trying to get to
get every everything to be uh properly
transmitted
between a actual computer file and
somebody going through and typesetting
it by hand and and typing it what they
what they think is a computer program no
I see I I don't unfortunately I didn't
save the galleys from this programming
pearls article but this was very amply
demonstrated on this on this sample
program at the end here this was types
that this was typed set by the uh
Waverly press and a tremendous number of
errors were on the galley cruise and I
caught most of them and John caught some
that I didn't catch and and uh We've and
we just it was absolutely clear that
this method of of of publishing programs
would not work if it required another
human being in the in the uh in the in
in the pipeline in the whatever we call
it the loop
um between between the computer program
and the printing press but but there has
to but it has to be a a computer control
going from the from the source to the to
the uh
to the type setting in order to get it
right
there's just there's just so many
chances for errors otherwise and that
and that's what we've does we've we've
included the formatting that uh that
will that will insert indentations and
and uh bold face and italics and and so
on according to these conventions of
Myrtle Kellington
and um other formerly conventions people
like that they can also adopt and they
could build such systems too this this
uh this whole idea it doesn't depend on
Tech and Pascal you can substitute for
Tech any type setting language you could
substitute for Pascal any
programming language and and people are
are developing things like this with
lisp for example as a programming
language and there's t-roth and C
versions
that uh that that have been developed
and so on
um
the uh the only problem is I guess
somebody has also actually tried to use
Tech and Tech uh to use this system for
for writing Tech macros and then we had
a little promise to what to name these
files because they both had the same
name both were name Tech fines um
but but that was the only uh okay so
well now
so this is uh an idea that seems to be
working reasonably well now
um in at least the uh the the second
last issue of the communications this uh
um I think it's the September 87 issue
now has has a a new column called
literate programming or something which
is scheduled to appear three times a
year which is uh which is a based on the
reaction to this article that that
Bentley wrote his he said that there was
more more mail
um produced by this uh by the by this
article and anything else that uh uh
that they can remember at the
communications and so it it it it it uh
re it touched the nerve of some sort
anyway that people were looking for
better ways to communicate uh computer
programs
um now I expect what I want to talk
about the rest of this week is the
experiments that I did earlier this year
with uh with with nine undergraduates
who were working with me on a research
project and I asked them to to write
some programs in the web system and see
what and to see see what they went
through learning it because it I never
had I had only only done it myself using
it you know my own experience was was uh
uh too personal I couldn't separate
myself from it and if it was anything
about this system I didn't like I could
easily change it
but somebody else gets it and they and
they might have to fight the system
because they because they don't have the
freedom to change it when they want to
and so I so I um I want to show you some
of the experiments that that um
that went on there the the first and
second drafts of the of the programs
that the students wrote that's why but
I'd like you to prepare yourself for
that by reading by reading this article
I'll ask Jim is today I want to say just
a couple of things about
um computer
uh user manuals now we'll say more about
it later because everyone knows this is
a blight on the industry uh uh the I
talked to Lyle Nelson of the
communications department and and he
says oh he's so glad you're you have a
a course on writing in computer science
department because the computer manuals
I've been reading are so terrible and
and uh and in fact uh it's really it's
really scandalous the way
uh the way manuals
um come out now
um and I was going to try to just bring
you a couple of uh of bad examples
um but I didn't succeed in finding the
worst examples not some so maybe if some
of you have examples of your favorite uh
of your favorite terrible errors in in
user manuals please bring them to class
and Wednesday and Friday and I'll be and
I'll be able to use them this week or
next week but I I'm I want to take up a
collection here of of really glaring
errors in in user manuals that you've
seen I have to report that I I I I I I I
read
the dbase 3 manual that my wife had a
year ago and I thought it was pretty bad
and so I went back to her shelf to get
the manual so that I could Xerox some of
the pages to show you how how bad it was
but they had come up with dbase 3 plus
and the whole brand new manual and I
looked at the new manual and actually
that's probably the first computer
manual for a PC that I had ever seen
that I thought was was actually
respectively done and and like and I
couldn't find anything to complain about
in fact it looked like they had thought
about that rather well in this in this
second version so maybe I should even
bring that in as a good example to show
but
um
it was
um but but
um somehow bad examples are more fun so
so please bring in some bad examples for
me to look at
now
I wanted to make a few General comments
here that the most most of these manuals
are written by somebody who thinks
they're trying to write for the absolute
novice
and uh and that's a that's reasonably
that I mean that's a good thing to try
um
and uh
uh and there's and the only trouble is
that there's usually accompanied by a
paragraph that that uh that says that
this is for the absolute novice followed
by another paragraph which makes it
absolutely clear that it's not
um and here's here's one that I got in
the mail last week uh this is a proposed
manual for me for PC meta font and it
says it may is this I like this
paragraph very much it may at times see
Mrs males if we're belaboring a point or
repeating ourselves needlessly if so
please have patience keep in mind that
you may have a greater knowledge of our
ability to learn about computer systems
than some other users however we're help
attempting to help everyone discover the
rewards and so on so now that sounds
great now the next paragraph though says
for text listings whether they're part
of input file or output for all the
characters something shall note the spot
where an implied concatenated line
exists the line following that with the
concatenated symbol should be considered
it will be invented two character widths
now I don't understand what the heck the
guy sung about and I wrote metaphon and
I you know now
and so finally after seeing a whole a
bunch of examples it was clear that
really the this is much narrower they
wanted to show lines that are much that
are narrower than their page I mean a
lot lighter than their page and so they
wanna to show that something was that
that's two lines in this book is
actually one line in a file but that's
not what it says here
um
now the the uh
let's see the timer's about up but I
want to show you this anyway there's a
book that came out last week and it's
probably one of the best computer
science books of the Year probably the
best uh it's uh by three people who read
who I mean two of them are excellent
writers and
um and um it's uh it's about the awk
language which uh the initials a w k is
what what of the authors is what is what
led to this uh is what led to this
language and they they don't say in
their preface but they they try to write
this manual so that it would be for
someone who has no experience with uh
with other with other programming
languages
and uh and uh now in the beginning of
the uh of the preface it um so anyway
this was and and Al gave a copy of this
to my wife so that she because it seems
like awk is really the system of choice
for her with uh kind of of work that
that she does on her PC
um and so uh uh uh but when when Jill
got to um
um
the third paragraph all of a sudden here
it was um
oh wait what am I saying here um
she knows about regular expression she's
she's heard about that term actually
before but here she says Zach act the
action language looks like C but there
are no declaration strings and numbers
are built in data types and all of a
sudden uh now now every now of course uh
the authors Al Kernan Weinberger
wouldn't understand that that Jill has
just one word for declarations and data
types and that is gobbledygook this
sounds like Godly good as far as she
knows and know what any of this is any
computer science knows this now um and
so on the next page it says uh why is
awk a good language because there are no
declarations because storage management
is easy it has the advantages of
pseudocode
but they can be run which is not true of
pseudocode and so and then there's make
programs and all these things now you
have to explain this to the to some
class of readers but but uh there would
be you know but this this completely
turned off uh uh Jill and schwashi still
uh is gainly going through the the
examples in the book and this book is by
the way has more than a thousand
examples of art programs in it and each
one has been tested and
and run with awk and actually types it
by computer so that they're correctly
transcribed and everything that's a very
fine feature of it
um and and I think it's well written
book even though it suffers from this
problem but I want to but but this is
inherent no matter what if if you if you
are
a person who's been into in a field for
very long you won't realize when you're
using jargon but when you're trying to
but if you take as a goal to try to
write for a novice user you will at
least be writing very clearly to the
people who are like you
and this this will make you look very
much more successful and if you try to
write for a high level user and then
then you would confuse everybody so so
so uh I would say it's you know even
though you you Mike does not be able to
succeed because you just aren't a novice
uh it's still worthwhile to try writing
for the novice uh because then you will
you will very well communicate with the
experts and otherwise you communicate
with nobody
okay